a woman freaked out on an American
Airlines flight over the weekend and
since we now live in a culture that
encourages people to film people in
distress rather than to help them the
poor lady has gone viral I'm telling you
I'm getting the off and there's a
reason why I'm getting them open
everyone
either Believe it or they cannot believe
it I don't give two
but I am telling you
that back there is not real
and you can sit on this plane and you
can die with them or not I'm not going
to so what happened was the woman having
a psychotic break
did she have a few too many drinks at
the airport bar sweet beautiful drunk
tough was her seat mate not real
I don't know it seems unlikely but maybe
Matt's right and she saw an alien